first on cbs this morning we are
revealing a new campaign aimed at
changing the conversation around sexual
violence within the black community
we as ourselves was created by metoo
international the times up foundation
and the national women's law center
today
i pledge i pledge
we pledge our commitment to show up for
you we promise to get refocused around
how the realities of sexual violence
plagues our communities and weakens the
bonds that we have with each other
we are committed to raising our voices
in love
and solidarity even when it's hard even
when it's complicated
if you're seeing this or hearing this
know that you won't have to go it alone
any longer boy one in five black women
are rape survivors one in four black
girls
experience sexual abuse me too founder
and executive director that's tarana
burke and actress journey smallett
who you just saw at the end of the video
join us now to discuss good morning to
you both
i love the video i think it's so
powerful so important and
so needed toronto please start us off
with what you hope
how you hope this will change the
conversation on this topic in the black
community
well one hi good morning first of all
and thank you for having us
but i really hope that we can start
having the conversation more in the
black community
right now we don't even talk about it
enough you know outside of
accusations against famous men
where we have to have debates about
who's right and who's wrong and who did
what we don't really talk about
survivors and the black women and girls
and boys and men and trans and queer
folks who are dealing with sexual
violence in our community
outside of you know popularized um
conversations yeah i hadn't thought
about it that way you really said it
let's just have the conversation let's
just start with that yeah
journey what inspired you to get
involved
well i mean i've always been inspired by
tarana
and um the metoo movement that she
founded so long ago
and we've in partnership just
collaborated on a number of projects and
it's it's just been something gnawing at
all of us you know that we have to
acknowledge
that mainstream media pop culture the
society at large
greatly show up how greatly influenced
how we show up in conversations about
sexual violence and how we do not
support black survivors
and we're just tired of being sick and
tired you know we're tired of the
erasure of the black female narrative
we're tired of
seeing our black femmes
queer folks um girls you know
non gen uh gender non-conforming
survivors we're we're tired of seeing
them
muted in silence and so we're just
deciding to show up and like tarana said
just have the conversation
tarana it's anthony one one of the
startling things
in this is the statistic that i saw that
for every black woman who reports rape
at least 15 black women do not
why are black women less likely to
report assaults
well there's so many reasons one being
that we're not believed and i think
that's kind of universal right that
people
tend not to believe survivors but in the
black community there's this extra onus
on us to protect
our perpetrator who you know and that's
not to say that they're always black men
but
when it is a black man there's an extra
onus to protect our perpetrator
there's also been a culture of silence
in our community around sexual violence
that says you know you'll get over it
you'll be fine there are more important
things to focus on so we don't come
forward because
you don't want to create more trouble in
the community you don't want to create
more trouble in your family
and so there's an extra burden and we
see this around with black women in
general right there's always an extra
burden that we have to take on an extra
level of responsibility
and we don't even get to center
ourselves you know that statistic that
anthony
uh just said to you tarana stuck out to
me i did an interview with fka twigs
where you talked last week where you
talk about famous men she's speaking out
publicly for the first time
on camera about the emotional uh
physical
verbal abuse that she suffered from him
and this sort of backs up exactly what
you're saying
i want you to hear this well i felt like
i had to overcome judgment and
discrimination
before i could even get to talking about
what had happened to me
and she says that she was told that when
she sought help
from women who specialize in getting you
to talk does that resonate with you
absolutely it absolutely does and i
think a lot of times
you know we do it out of safety you'll
you'll have an older black person in
your family
you know auntie a cousin or somebody
he'll say well listen you know you don't
want to cause problems
you just just you'll get over it it'll
be fine you know
there's just other things that we have
to worry about in this moment
just think about last summer we had this
uprising and everybody was talking about
being anti-racist and we were and racism
was the conversation of the day
and when i would bring up about police
you know police violence and sexual
violence and where they intersect people
say
this is not the time to talk about that
i said well when is the time
journey you know we we concentrate so
much about women but i want to talk to
you about your son you have a young son
how old is he now and i'm curious about
the conversation you're having with them
because
young boys and young men have to be
included in this conversation too
oh absolutely um i will do some
four-year-old son
he's four yeah and
my goal honestly in raising him is to do
exactly how my mother did in raising
my four brothers you know in in making
them
a center of the conversation just like
she made us
you know um not just making them allies
but making them advocates she
trained them to correct their friends
when they saw inappropriate behavior she
would say
okay if they if they call a girl out of
their name or if they're
disrespectful to a black female then you
have to
stand up you have to voice your opinion
and
they are held accountable just like
everybody else
and um it's it's it's
part of the conversation right like just
having the conversation at your dinner
table
in your basement you're exactly right
your your son's very lucky we're gonna
have to leave it there
journey smaller we thank you can i add
to that well
i'm sorry i'm gonna touch you i really
gotta go
go ahead go ahead okay i just wanna i
just wanted to add that we have to also
engage boys and men not just as
perpetrators but they're also survivors
and this is also about black men and boy
survivors right very very very good
point as well
thank you toronto thank you do you have
a segment coming up journey small out i
hope lovecraft country's coming back
you were knockout and i hope so me too
you're watching cbs this morning we'll
be right back